va à la réalité il y a beaucoup de miel sur le
visage de celui-ci le pic cramoisi parle d'un
ancien manoir avec de sombres secrets la
romance gothique est une tradition très séculaire
qui se rapproche vraiment du plus sombre
des contes de fées je comprends votre
fascination pour l'Edith de Sharpe
c'est  ma sœur mais continuez avec prudence
il y a plusieurs histoires contradictoires dans
ce film qui se tissent ensemble et
crée beaucoup de drame et de danger il
y a une jeune femme au centre qui
est purement innocente ses pensées grandes larges
et ouvertes et ça rétrécit et ça  devient
ce mystère très intense que je dois
laisser il est finalement une histoire sombre et
longue elle a tout ce que parfois les
gens font par amour est ce que ces films
sur
vous n'ont nulle part où aller l'amour fait des
monstres d'une âme
vous